hey guys my name is Jess Mixel and it is
officially day 1 of a 3 that's kind of
confusing since we've been watching
press conferences for two days now but
let's roll with it I've got the lowdown
for you on all the coolest stuff that
happened at the Ubisoft Sony's Nintendo
and Square Enix press conferences that's
right to prepare the information
overload you be sobs i should tyler
hosted press conference was a pretty
good mix of what we were expecting and
some pretty cool surprises Ubisoft
showed off a pvp arena for tom clancy's
the division called the dark zone and it
was revealed that the game will be out
on march eight Rainbow six siege got an
extended gameplay demo and a new
cinematic trailer giving us a better
idea of both the story and the
multiplayer maps it was also revealed
that the beta will land on sep tember 24
trials fusion got an insane expansion
featuring a tiger riding a unicorn
called awesome level max and we got our
first look at a South Park sequel which
i'm personally definitely going to play
cause the fractured butthole say it a
few times fast if you didn't get the
joke Ubisoft rounded off their presser
with Ghost Recon wildlands which will be
four player co-op and feature an
open-world that reacts to play at
choices Sony was up next and this one
was absolutely huge if you only watch
one press conference from e3 2015 make
it this one it's a serious crowd lupa
sony kicked off by finally revealing the
Last Guardian with a lovely gameplay
trailer and a 2016 release date which
you'd be smart to be wary of we've been
hurt before we were treated with a new
gameplay demo for no man's sky an
intriguing trail of the Destiny's next
expansion the taken King a
beautiful-looking Final Fantasy 7 remake
trailer and news of a Shenmue 3
Kickstarter which is already raised over
two and a half million bucks in less
than 12 hours yeah I'm gonna give you a
minute to process all that other awesome
things included a sweet-looking gameplay
video for guerrilla games
new IP called horizon zero dawn and a
trailer for the new hitman game which is
simply called hitman Square Enix likes
to keep it confusing sony also delivered
on some survival mode gameplay from Star
Wars Battlefront and there were new
trailers the street fighter 5 and
Assassin's Creed syndicate which finally
showed off its badass female protagonist
Evie and it was everything we'd hoped it
would be Nintendo brought the weird and
the wonderful as always kicking off its
press conference with a lengthy Muppet
filled clip unfortunately there wasn't
that much to get super excited for from
then on out the major announcement of
the conference was info on Star Fox for
Wii U it's called Star Fox zero it's
launching this holiday and Platinum
Games is co-developing alongside
Nintendo Xenoblade Chronicles X now has
a US release date of december five this
year and a trailer for Animal Crossing
happy home designer warmed everyone's
hearts Super Mario maker got a sep
tember 11 of 2015 release date and the
multiplayer game the legend of zelda
triforce heroes was announced as a
successor to four swords finally Square
Enix rounded out the bevy of press
conferences with a bunch of gaming
tidbits if you're a fan of JRPGs you
would have been right at home Square
Enix showed off some just cause 3
footage and revealed that the game will
ship on December first it will feature a
400 square mile map for you to gallivant
around and an awful lot of things for
you to blow up it was announced that
final fantasy 7 that's the PC to console
port not the new HD remake would be
delayed to winter but it's also coming
to iOS also revealed was a sequel to
drakengard spin-off near developed with
assistance from platinum games and fans
of Kingdom Hearts 3 were beyond excited
when square finally showed off gameplay
hey December 8 2015 release date for
hitman was revealed and it was announced
of that Deus Ex mankind divided woodland
early next year we're also showed off a
mankind divided trailer which delved
deeper into Adam Jensen story and new
abilities finally we got to look at some
concept art from squares next
big RPG chew out next year it's called
Project setsuna at the moment and it's
being developed by the new studio tokyo
RPG factory let me know down in the
comments which games have been pressed
to you so far from e3 and which press
conference has been your favorite
personally my vote has to go to Sony be
sure to stay tuned to gain squad for all
the latest news trailers and info from
our lecture I'll catch again tomorrow
you